oh i've actually even played smack my
bishop before
can't remember who i played
that's a shame oof
i'm gonna go for a sideline against the
king's gambit
it's really a nerve-wracking to be so
old and so slow
for those who are watching
who are old and slow i don't know how
you do it
how do you deal with that every day i
find it pretty hard
this stuff probably doesn't work at all
d knight g4
but yeah probably wasn't very good
but i'm gonna play in gambit style
it's okay it is all good
ed now yeah queen c4 bishop
queen 22 bishop c4 was all i think just
a little bit too loose
i had d5 there as well knight c6 was
good but
this one feels like sort of the simplest
way to get
to get a nice advantage
castles just d5 protecting the knight
obviously queen e4 then rookie 8 was
happening
knight e5 would have been forced and
then i just go
[Music]
d and whichever way it takes i think i
have a nice development advantage and
the better position uh
and here as well
you do play the king's gambit but some
of the time
the f4 pawn is really gonna be a thorn
in your side
um and there is no way you can run run
run
away from it um
if the pawn was on f2 then he would have
had a lot
less problems here um
and here
i'm not only winning the pawn back on d4
um but for weakness also means that
uh he's gonna have serious problems with
the bishop on c1 developing that one and
also
there's gonna be tempo with the bishop
coming on coming to d4
later on so he's now in the world of
trouble
uh
okay uh you know what i'm gonna i'm
going i'm gonna go for a little bit of
fun here
knight e4 and please take it
if you're if you're if you're sniping
the the live stream please stick on d4
oh that's such a shame so let me tell
you what i planned
knight d4 i wanted bishop f5 queen f5
queen d4 king h1 queen f2
such a shame he didn't allow that and
for instance knight d2
rookie one queen d3 queen g1 was made
now this just wins very precisely
but i'm really really upset about that
maybe i should have gone
queen d3 bishop f5 first
but it looks so much cleaner to go
knight d4 and then
bishop f5 hmm ugh
that was disappointing
but anyway i think the game the game's
gonna be
gonna be over fairly soon we got similar
themes here
queen to d4 let's see if i can at least
get a nice
checkmate here let let's see if i can
get it
it's not gonna be quite the same as the
checkmate i was hoping for but
um
but still nice
my opponent says he's going back going
back to the red wine
which is a reference to oh there we go
that's the checkmate
which is a reference to the beloved's
character
that he has in his profile picture yeah
gg
thank you